look here's what I want to know is there
anything else in the free world like the
Super Bowl no there really doesn't seem
to be I mean I just went to the Ryder
Cup the big international golf thing and
that that does not really nothing really
compared to this I mean you just
mentioned Oscars that might kind of have
the same kind of hub up but no there's
nothing like the Super Bowl um your
whole you're doing a whole thing about
getting close up to people I'll let you
explain it as I stand closer to you go
ahead right no I did this commercial for
a Colgate Total and they'd never done a
Super Bowl ad before and I've never done
a Super Bowl ad before either so it's
actually it was really fun to do it and
yeah did this thing where it's about a
close talker in the office to where the
guy I don't even want to do it to you
but like when we did the ad would just
get like this far away it's crazy when
people close talk yeah I was just
talking to somebody he said a waiter had
done it to him the other night but I
think the I've had a couple of directors
that were close talkers and I remember
my high school football coach he used to
get very close to me while he was
talking to me you know what Matthew
McConaughey's a close talker he is a
close talker yes he is yeah it's just a
I've met him a couple of times I didn't
realize that I might adjust I might have
just been happy to be talking to him you
get so excited that you don't mind that
he gets real close okay so let me ask
you this
give me three times when it is
appropriate to close talk someone love
scene if you're trying to make a serious
point maybe if somebody is sad
good no no those are good talking to a
small child good time to close something
poor children they have to get close
talk to you all the time
I do it sometimes to my dog I have to
close talk to my dog meanwhile I want to
ask you about Legally Blonde what are we
here are you going back what's the deal
and this is the honestly I'm not I all
I've heard is the same thing everybody
else is heard as if they might be doing
Legally Blonde three but yeah I can't
imagine anything that would be more fun
just Reese played such a great character
and yeah I've not loved do Legally
Blonde 3 you would yeah I'd definitely
be up for it so you put your bid in
there we go that is set oK we've laid
that ground
[Music]